I will never argue with a day of talking
about Dracula so I'm in good shape at
the moment okay I also did want to dig
into to clemens's backstory a little bit
I know we get some information in the
film but I'm always looking for more so
is there any specific details you came
up with on your own that you know maybe
we don't see or hear about in the film
but we could feel informing your
performance how he carries himself and
the choices he makes throughout all this
yeah Clemens uh for me was it was
important in our in my conversations
with the producers uh with Andre that
whatever
um whatever we do with Clemens I think
he he just needed to he needed to make
sense and it just needed to be honest
and
um and so that led to a lot of research
um because I've become a bit of a nerd
when it comes to my characters it
doesn't matter how off-kilter or
whatever it is I wanna I'm a student
when I when I dip into these different
worlds and time periods and stuff and so
it was important to research these these
black men who were Cambridge educated or
or whatever sort of Higher Learning
during that time at the turn of the
century like that was important to me to
just highlight that and if if he's going
to be a black man it gotta it has to
make sense and so it just was a little
bit more digging into into that and also
what I found out was that a lot of um
American uh Black American men mostly
would have gone overseas in order to get
that higher education
um now whether or not they'd be able to
practice it practice their trade or
their occupation was another story but I
think that just informed a lot of his
journey because like he says in the film
his reputation preceded him but is the
color of his skin didn't and so
um there was information there about him
being the other about you evil and the
things that he confronted on the
day-to-day so when he confronts
this other evil presence named Dracula
you know on this boat what does that
mean because Dracula is also the other
and he is the other and what do they see
in each other as well so I I just
thought it was fascinating and just to
explore that without hitting the nail on
the head or being didactic about it but
it's like it's the reality of it like
I'm a black man about to go and do this
role and and we have to make it make
sense I always appreciate that level of
research and preparation but on the
other side of it there's always
opportunity to discover new things about
your character along the way so can you
isolate something specific you learned
about Clemens but only because you were
on set working with your scene partners
and Andre in the thick of it yeah I
think
um specifically with Clemens it was his
uh it was his journey it was it was also
realize that
I learned that I'm a bit claustrophobic
um but I think I think it was just
realizing that this man of science
um he's someone when he talks earlier in
the film about
um finding the seeing the goodness in
people and wondering why there's so much
good in the world and yet you know
um evil things still happen to good
people or whatever he's pondering
something it's a bit of a foreshadow
because like he's he's he's trying to
there's this level of adaptability he
that he has that he isn't allowing
himself he's a scientist so when he's
presented with Dracula in the
Supernatural he doesn't want to believe
it and I think it's the adaptability of
who he is that separates him from it's
this Constitution that he had growing up
you know that separates him from uh from
from the other Sailors on the boat he
grew up a sailor you know in terms of
the backstory his father he saw his
father on boats and so he's aware of all
of the ships myths and cobbles and all
of that kind of stuff but what's what's
what's
but the man he's had to become is a man
of ones and zeros science in order to
get through the world but in order to
survive he has to be adaptable and I
think it's just such a it was just such
a cool lesson for me to watch Clemens
sort of go on it's like oh oh I get it
and talking with Andre and the producers
through that and and the other actors in
this with with Ashling and who plays
Anna like just just finding out new
things about our characters as we as we
were going over the months of shooting
this it was layers make him especially
exciting to track
I have a personal question now about uh
the roles that you jump into because
there was a quote from you in our
production notes that caught my eye it
was saying something to the effect of
you tend to run towards things that
scare you as an actor so it was just
making me wonder whether it's this
project or anything else you've done
thus far which role do you deem the
scariest that you've tackled so far oh
um
well this is my first time actually I
would say
stepping into a bit of a lead lead role
um taking the helm and like actually you
know number one on the call sheet and
actually having to take that
responsibility on but also learning how
to lead and learning how to just uh what
what makes a good leader on a set
um I've had some great mentors and the
you know Sam Jackson's and Denzel
Washington's and Francis mcdormands and
all those incredible talents of the
world
um but it was it's scary it's a bit of a
challenge and so my thing is like I
don't really want to do it unless it
excites me and it's a marathon and it's
not a Sprint so yeah I'm gonna run to
the things to scare me I'm gonna run and
and go play go do a British accent I
mean I I know how you know how it could
be received if it if it isn't done well
and and but I also know that like why do
it if you're not stretching yourself and
I want to look back and just say oh yeah
I've tackled that I've tackled this I've
tackled these different
um things and not because I'm like
picking these trying to think I'm just
like I'm going after what is different
and what appeals to me they came to me
with this opportunity
um it's been around for a while
different iterations of it and and they
and we got it made which was which is
really cool to bring Dracula back with
this this this uh this new version of
Dracula or old version I guess I could
say in a complete turn here I'm gonna
wrap up with one question about a future
project because The Color Purple looks
absolutely incredible and that Ensemble
is seriously something else and given
that this feels like a bit of an unfair
question to ask but based on the trailer
alone it does seem like every single
actor is going to deliver a jaw-dropping
performance so is there any particular
cast member you could highlight who just
like blew you away on that set did
something with the role that you never
could have imagined and you know you
want to celebrate them and put them in
the spotlight a little leading to up to
release that is a very unfair question I
know but what I will but with you it's
your job to ask those unfair hard
questions sometimes I'm glad you're
open-minded to that they do it well
um I I honestly my first of all my
intent going into Color Purple was to
celebrate and lift these women
and their stories period Point Blank I
am of support in support of I get
emotional when I think about the work
that they do on that set but it's from
Taraji to Fantasia Hallie I mean it's
just Felicia who plays young SI it
literally was just incredible to watch
Coleman deliver playing my father but
Danielle Brooks is my classmate from
Juilliard we used to sing Color Purple
in the in the hallways and joke around
and stuff like that and when we
graduated she did it on Broadway
um and I told them and I knew they were
going to ultimately go to Danielle but I
told them when I got Harpo I was like
she has to be Sophia and and the
producers were like we know we know
I'm like she has to be you know she has
to be so far I I have to be her Harpo
that's what it is she doesn't have to be
I have to be her Harpo and she delivers
an outstanding performance in this in
Color Purple so I just want to say does
not surprise me one bit to hear that I
can't wait to see that huge
congratulations on this and everything
you've accomplished I can't wait to see
you chase more roles that scare you in
the future thank you thank you very much
it's good to talk to you